[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to chess
openings explained as always my name is
caleb denby
and tonight i am going to be talking to
you about a little bit of a more
beginner focused
openings lecture uh we're just coming
off of i think a nine part
f3 nimzo series and when you spend nine
lectures
going uh over you know in-depth lines
in-depth variations going very deep
into middle game plans as well it can
get a little bit you know
daunting you start to lose sight of what
actually is going on in the opening
and that's sort of what i want to talk
about here tonight
the title of the lecture i think is
something like weak squares and bad
gambits
and that is what we're specifically
going to be looking at
but in general the main point i hope you
get across uh i hope i get across
tonight
is that chess starts sort of from the
first move and
uh by far the most common mistake i see
made
by big beginners and sort of you know
amateur tournament level players alike
is that they take these opening
principles or they take their opening
theory
and what they do is they use that
instead of
thinking and it's really important to
understand and i think this is not
communicated well to beginners enough
the opening principles are not your
replacement for thinking
they are you know a guide to help your
thinking right they're
sort of a tool that leads you to think
about which moves could be correct
not something you use to replace
thinking you don't just say okay i'm
going to play by the opening principles
and i'll you know
things will be great i don't have to
think chess starts from the first move
and you have to be sort of on your toes
thinking
from that early early stage so to start
with
i want to show you guys a game that i
actually played against a friend of mine
who we
are going to call tim so i had the white
pieces and tim
had the black pieces here and tim
doesn't really play chess he plays
casually he knows the rules
but he never really studied it at all
seriously or anything he just likes
you know he plays chess like like any of
us would play another board game right
maybe you know the rules maybe you've
played it a few times but
uh it's not like you've done any study
so let's see how this game goes
i start with d4 and tim responds in kind
with d5
and so i play c4 the the queen's
gambit of course so i'm temporarily
sacrificing my pawn on c4
in return for control of the center so
tim decided he was actually going to
take this
and then declared victory because he was
ahead up a pawn this actually happened
of course he was joking but for the
moment tim
is up a pawn so before we move on any
further of course this is not one of
those
bad gambits that i'm talking about in
the title we'll get to that
in a little bit here so what does white
get
in exchange for this pawn well for one
white gets control over the e4 and c4
squares
now how is this so how does sacrificing
a pawn on c4
actually give white control over these
squares well
of course with this pawn on d5 white
does not have control over these squares
so i can never really play the move e4
or else it'll be captured and while we
saw what happened after i played c4
in this case tim decided he did want to
take my pawn
but now that this pawn has captured on
c4 it can no longer defend these squares
so at its core you know this may seem
like really really basic stuff and it is
but white is weakening black's control
of yes the center which is probably how
it's been phrased
before if you've had this talk before
but also these two squares specifically
and these are
light squares so if you play the queen's
gambit accepted
you know even if you know the theory
it's important to understand that by
taking this pawn on c4
you are inherently weakening your light
squares
and so you should be cautious of
weakening the light squares even further
that's why after knight f3 my opponent's
next move while it may follow
opening principles to some extent is
actually a pretty bad one
so black can do any number of things
here you can develop a piece with
something like knight f6
you could even potentially develop this
knight out to d7
uh you could play c5 to challenge this
pawn you could even play a6
threatening to to keep your own pawn
these are all viable moves
but what tim did here was actually a
pretty bad
so tim plays the move bishop g4 and you
know at first glance
it may seem like a perfectly fine move
right we're following all the opening
principles
right all black has done is captured a
free pawn on c4
and then developed a piece so how can
this be so bad
well if you use this sort of thinking
where you just solely rely on the
principles and you don't really
you know use use your brain you don't
really think about it as a chest
position from move one
then seemingly nothing is wrong with
this but
you know using this idea that i just
talked about where
we understand that by capturing on c4 we
have weakened light squares
we now understand that moving this
bishop out
further weakens light squares right now
we see that this pawn
on b7 is going to be weak and this
bishop on c8
could have you know been useful in
defending perhaps a check from this
diagonal
even defending along this diagonal it
may have potentially been useful
but now it's committed itself out to the
g4 square
and worse than that it gives white an
avenue to actually start attacking these
light squares so chat
i want you guys to try and come up with
my next move
in this game using this sort of
principle thinking that we've been
talking about
right black has weakened the light
squares by capturing on c4
and further weakened some squares by
moving this bishop out from its
defensive spot on c8
so how can we start to take advantage of
this chat what do you guys think and
yeah
the chat has a great idea already and
that move is 95
and that's what i played in the game so
this move in particular
is one big reason why bishop g4 is not
so good
but on top of that even i want to say
principally
but not by those simple opening
principles of develop pieces control the
center
castle the king right black was sort of
following those
but principally by weakening light
squares black should no longer
really be playing these types of moves
that only serve to further weaken
the light squares in their camp so
with the white pieces we should be
looking to attack these squares
so 95 gains a tempo on the bishop and
also starts to look at these light
squares in the black camp
and you know while so far principled
black has
actually made some pretty serious
mistakes with this move
well actually just just the one mistake
with bishop g4
but it's enough to give white a pretty
pleasant advantage just by ignoring this
simple idea
where black has weakened light squares
so we should not weaken them further
and even worse you've allowed this white
knight to e5 where it can start to
target
some of those loose squares now that
being said of course black isn't losing
yet by any stretch
that is until tim's next move which was
f5
so obviously this one is pretty bad
and this was a case i believe of
a little advice and a little misguided
advice
uh is sometimes worse than no advice at
all or having a little bit of knowledge
on something
is sometimes worse than having no
knowledge at all so
the reason why tim played f5 i talked to
him about it after the game
and he said that he thinks
you know let's just say hypothetically
we continue somehow
that knights are really powerful when
developed out behind a pawn
and this is true this is really this is
super true
that's why on the queen side you'll
often play c4 before playing knight c3
it's because the pawn and the knight
control the same squares and that's
really powerful
it gives you really great con really
great control over those two squares
so this was the reasoning that you know
tim had
decided on for playing f5 followed by by
knight f6
and it's important to understand here
that's uh
well maybe to the chat room and to me f5
looks like a pretty horrible move
there is like logic behind it right the
you know at its core
it doesn't sound like such a bad idea if
you ignore
the fact that all the light squares are
critically weak and that of course is
why f5 is a bad move
because it shuts this bishop out from
defending the light squares
it further weakens these light squares
by moving this pawn forward
and now black is is simply lost four
moves
into the game uh but if you sort of turn
your brain off
and say well black followed the
principles right black
captured a free pawn developed a piece
and then defended the attacked piece so
why is black losing well
it's because black wasn't really
engaging with the position
uh as a chess position black was marge
so just
sort of auto piloting i think up until
f5
so much better would have been to save
this bishop with something like bishop
h5
or maybe even better is bringing it back
to e6 sort of admitting
hey my my light squares are a little bit
weak maybe i should try
to defend them but instead f5 and now of
course the winning move here
is going to be to immediately uh attack
on these light squares
and i did so with queen a4 check right
this bishop can no longer come back to
defend
and black doesn't really have a
comfortable way to
block on this diagonal black should try
knight d7
but this is not going to be enough for
equality it's not really going to be
anywhere anywhere near equality there
are numerous ways to continue queen b5
is fine queen takes c4 is good for white
kicking this bishop away is also good
for white taking advantage
of even more light squared weaknesses by
attacking those squares with the pawns
but in the game we never got to we never
got that far because tim played knight
c6
and so once again sort of the natural
looking move but of course here
uh it is simply just underdefended on c6
and black went on to lose pretty quickly
i captured on c6
captures captures queen d7 would now
lose the rook on a8
so king f7 was played ends and then i
play the move e4
with the idea being bishop takes c4
check is going to follow next
and unfortunately for tim he snagged
this pawn
on d4 threatening checkmate but it was
not good enough
because bishop takes c4 comes with check
and there's no good way to get out of
this check for black
if he were to block with the pawn then
this is simply checkmate
so tim sacrificed the queen and the game
ended
shortly thereafter with almost the same
checkmate on e6
so it's easy
to see that tim moves tim's moves in
this game
we're not the greatest particularly f5 i
think is what a lot of people would
latch on to
but i wanted to start with this basic
example to sort of show you
uh what it looks like in the basic form
when
you know the player with the black
pieces maybe doesn't notice all the
threats in the position
and is sort of just flying blind this is
what it looks like
so once again what we want to take from
this game is this idea
of understanding that you know chess
starts
from the first move and in this case
black has already made a really
important decision
by move two and it's important to play
sort of according to that decision
understanding these squares that you've
weakened understanding that you need to
be cautious of the light squares and for
that reason you often see this bishop
just sitting on c8
sort of for the the entirety of the
opening
until black is certain that they have
regained
some control over those squares so
questions on this game
before i move on to a little bit of a
higher
higher level game
why not queen d7 after knight takes c6
so queen d7
was better but it is still losing but
yeah queen d7 is a better try
uh as for what would happen i think i
can actually
continue the tactics a little bit and
play bishop g2 here
and then uh this is just just quite bad
for uh quite bad for black sort of no
matter what you do i'm going to play
knight c3 next
and then move my knight and win the game
but good question
the tactics were a bit more complex
there
okay let us continue on that uh
so next up i want to sort of ratchet up
the the level a little bit
uh i want to take a look at two club
level tournament level players
that played a rapid game on chess.com
just a few days ago so this is actually
a game taken from the corporate chess
league
if you missed our big finale to the
corporate chess league
it was a pretty fun one pretty dramatic
finish if you guys are interested we
actually did stream it live
but i did want to highlight one game
that really does exemplify
this idea of the same light squares
becoming weak
and a d4 d5 opening so let's let's try
and understand why here and what happens
so this is a game
between dv dutch who i believe you know
may even be watching
tonight maybe not i haven't seen him in
the past couple lectures but he does
watch the lectures often
and someone by the name of now this is
just losing on chess.com so let's take a
look at how this game went
by the way i should say i just imported
this game from chess.com
this is not dv dutch's actual level i
think he's around 1500
uscf some somewhere in that range so a
thousand is is a bit underrated
uh just due to a lack of games on
chess.com but let's take a look
d4 d5 c4
in this case we don't see black actually
capturing on c4
we got the slav with pawn to c6
dv dutch then continued on with the
exchange
we see knight c3 knight f6
bishop f4 and bishop f5
so once again we see that uh
black is developing out this light
squared bishop outside the pawn chain as
we have been told to do
by principles but he's done so a little
bit
sort of cavalierly without caution
so white continues with e3 and you'll
notice that that white has done the same
thing here
black continues with e6 and then blight
plays the move queen to b3 and already
black black is significantly worse and i
think that
is probably a lot more surprising to
some of you than in the previous example
right it's easy to see that okay bishop
g4 knight e5
f5 in the first game of course white is
going to be better there
but here in the exchange slot on move
seven
white is already sort of at at least
plus
plus one and the reason for that is
black just has no good way to defend
these light squares on the queen side
and this goes back to to this thing that
i said at the top of the hour
chest really does start from the first
move
and so just because you're in the
opening just because
you are developing your pieces out
naturally doesn't mean
you don't have to think about the game
or else you risk things like this
that's happening to you where suddenly
out of nowhere it's move seven all
you've done is develop pieces
and you are are worse off so how can you
actually avoid it right
now now we understand that this is a bad
thing but what should black have been
thinking about here
so in the exchange slav what has
happened
well white has captured on d5
removing this c pawn from play
so what happens when you remove this
pawn from c6
from play when you trade it off for
white c pawn well number one
the queen has easy access to the queen
side as we saw in the game
and number two of course number one
before sorry number two
this pawn gets weakened on d5 because it
no longer has this defender
on c6 and you also lose a lot of control
over this diagonal in particular because
you can never have the option
to play this pawn out to c6 or just have
the pawn on c6
closing the diagonal so once again with
this opening
white has successfully weakened the
light squares
in black's camp so quite often
what you'll see done is players with
black pieces develop the queen side a
little bit right to compensate for this
they have light scored weaknesses on the
queen side
so it's important to develop out the
queen side pieces like this knight for
example
helping to guard this diagonal and just
guard squares on the queen side in
general
and then after we continue you'll quite
often hear even c players go as far
as to play the move a6 just to simply
control these light squares
prepare a move like b5 and compensate
for the fact that the c pawn is gone
and that white has easy inroads on this
side of the board
uh as for learning to recognize
these kinds of things in your games
without sort of memorizing moves
well that can be pretty tough that's
that's why
we always say uh we meaning you know
chess instructors
say the best way to learn is to analyze
your losses and analyze all your games
and look for spots where things started
to go wrong so
if you were playing this game with the
black pieces and it continued as
follows here white plays queen b3 you
realize hey
i don't really have a good way to defend
this b7 pawn
so you continue out with queen to d7 and
then your opponent hits you with the
winning tactic
which uh if you want to find it at home
go go ahead and pause here
is of course to simply remove the last
defender of the light squares on the
queen side
for black by removing this knight from
b8 and then
pinning the queen to the king with
bishop b5 and of course now
white is simply completely winning
better for black would have been to play
the move queen b6 sort of meeting white
and kind
but white is going to have some edge
here by
doubling these queenside pawns now
there's a lot to say about this
particular structure but just trust me
when i say that this is not a very good
version
mainly because these pawns can't ever
really even cross
the the b5 square white has good control
over this square
there are some situations where if black
is able to play something like b5 and b4
this can actually be perfectly fine but
in this case
really not a good structure for black
even though there is some compensation
down the a-file so white's going to be
better
now of course this is much better though
than queen d7 played in the game
when dv dutch did correctly find this
tactic and went on to win
pretty easily up the queen
so once again higher level players this
time 1500 online
it was a rapid game but i suspect
neither player would have spent much
more time in the opening
even if it weren't a rapid game uh just
having played in tournaments at this
level before
it doesn't really matter if the players
are 100 familiar
with the exact opening with the exact
opening line
they're going to move quickly right this
is sort of just how it always happens
at the 1500 level you sort of want to
get out of the opening so you can get to
the game so you can start thinking about
the middle game you know play
play the real chess but i'm here to tell
you that the real chess
it's happening in this opening it's
happening right away you have to be
thinking about these chess concepts
not just about opening principles so
questions on this example
before we we move along
uh ronam says you're a chess newcomer
sorry he says that he is a chess
newcomer how do you how do i analyze my
games effectively
so that that's a good question uh and
i would say that if you're on your own
and sort of trying to just
learn chess the hard way then the
computer can be a really useful tool
but it shouldn't really be uh this
massive crush
uh crutch so first i would start with
where you think
things actually went wrong and think
about without the computer how you could
have done better
and then you can flip on the computer
and sort of help it
ask for some help there where it can
suggest some moves
and then hopefully lead you to some some
better understanding there
so for example if you were to do this
with
black if you try to analyze this game
you might easily
write off queen d7 as the mistake say
that's why i lost the game queen d7 was
bad
but then when you realize that you
already don't have a good answer to
queen b3
that's when you have to start backing up
and saying well hold on well like how
how do i ever deal with my my queen side
light squares
and then hopefully you would arrive at
the conclusion that you sort of need
this bishop around to do it or you need
some more development here and you can
click around
with an opening database only chess for
example that that all
that all helps but that was all with the
caveat if you're doing this on your own
i think the best way to analyze your
games is to do so with your opponent if
possible or with a friend
uh you know preferably your friend is
better at chess than you but even just a
friend of any kind it's really helpful
to be analyzing with somebody to have
ideas to bounce off and
they can sort of counter your ideas as
well
okay let us
continue along then so this was sort of
the the two examples i really wanted to
show
on this idea of weak squares in the
opening
in particular we looked at two examples
where the light squared bishop was
developed out a little bit early
and then blocked out of the game in the
first game by f5 in the second game by
e6
and then white was able to score a quick
win because
of these weak squares and the main point
again that i'm trying to get across
is that you have to be thinking about
these moves right you can't just be
blindly relying on chess principles
because that's how you get the game that
i just looked at there
uh so now i want to jump to a different
type of game entirely and this is one
from the mid-1800s by the legendary paul
murphy and we're going to look at it
from his perspective actually
against napoleon and not napoleon
bonapartes
but a different napoleon who i believe
like participated in in a bunch of
american chess things
maybe i don't actually know where he was
from but he was a big chess player back
in the 1800s
definitely one of one of the world's
best at that time
although nobody was really competing
with paul morphy
at the time so let's take a look at this
game and talk about
what happened with white's play so we
have e4
e5 knight f3 knight c6
so far so normal bishop c4 and black
replied bishop c5
arriving at the joko piano the old quiet
game
and someone in the chat was actually
asking about the evans gambit before we
started
and that's actually what we see played
here white continues out with the move
b4 with the hope of distracting this
bishop from controlling the center
so we get bishop takes b4 now c3
continues to increase white's central
control black
retreats this bishop back to a5 white
continues now with d4
and black captures on d4 and this is
sort of in line
with the thinking of the day all these
like late 1800 games
even i think sometimes probably not
early 1900s i think they had things a
little bit more figured out then
but basically the the way they played
chess
uh was very romantic as you may know uh
it's called their
romantic era for a reason they believed
it was white's duty
to sacrifice material and try to play
for checkmate
and it was black's duty to capture that
extra material
and then hold on for dear life and if
you don't get checkmated then you get to
win because you have all the extra
pieces
uh and so that's why you see a lot of
these gambits from players with the
white pieces
and that's why you see players with the
black pieces sometimes naively
sort of fully accepting things like the
danish gambit just saying yeah
i'm taking all your pawns if you can
checkmate me then you win
but if you can't checkmate me then i win
that's just how they thought chess
should be played right white has the
first move white should go crazy
black has to go second so black should
just take the material and hope for the
best
and that's kind of what we see to some
extent going on here now the difference
with paul morphy
is that somehow he always seemed to take
the material when it was good
and always seemed to defend well when he
had to right this guy was sort of way
ahead of his time
okay so there's two main moves here for
whites number one is
castling which makes a lot of sense
right white wants to control the center
with the c
pawn right now it's pinned so castling
removes the pin
and number two is this move queen b3
which makes sense because it's attacking
these light squares so
let's talk about both of these moves
from our perspective
of thinking about it as a chess game not
just as an opening but as a chess game
from move one how can we arrive at these
two main moves
well we have to look at what the point
of this gambit is you have to understand
why white is playing the move b4
white plays the move b4 to gain time on
the bishop
and to loosen its control of the center
so with c3 we succeed in gaining time on
the bishop
and controlling the center d4 the
natural follow-up makes sense we want to
control the center
e takes d4 and now we have to make a
decision
with white right with move one
with e5 on move one black
has weakened the light squares by
denying himself the opportunity
to play e6 shutting this diagonal down
at a later date
that's what i'm saying man move one
that's when it starts
so that's why the move queen b3 is
perfectly reasonable
it fits in line with our gambit play we
gain time on the bishop for rapid
development and control the center
and so with this extra tempo we got with
c3 we can now consider playing the move
queen b3
and attacking this pawn on f7 directly
and then
continuing with our development
thereafter for example
the main line goes with queen e7 and
once again
king's side castles with the idea once
again
of capturing back on d4 controlling the
center
rapid development this is the goal of
the gambit but
white perhaps lost sight of this in the
game uh the other
move by the way is the immediate castles
which i think is a little bit more
obvious
than queen b3 and once again the idea
is mainly to simply recapture on
d4 and build your big center in exchange
for your pawn
right this was the goal of the evans
gambit all along
instead though white plays the move e5
and
this doesn't really make sense in line
with
uh with our gambit here it just doesn't
make that much sense
so why is that you know e5 seems like a
perfectly reasonable move it takes away
space
from uh from your opponent and it
sort of goes to to develop some kind of
attack perhaps
but you have to understand that gambits
are not about checkmating the king
as fast as possible that's what they
didn't understand back in the 1800s and
that's what a lot of players
at you know sort of the beginner level
don't understand still today
it's not about checkmate it's not about
immediately checkmating your opponent if
that's the reason why you're playing a
gambit
then you're probably not playing that
gambit correctly
and so this is my advice to anybody
who's thinking about trying those
those crazy gambits that you see online
it's it's fine to try them some of them
are
quite fun some of them are good some of
them do end in checkmate rather quickly
but that's not the goal of a gambit
the goal of a gambit is to develop your
pieces quickly it's to control the
center it's to hamper your opponent's
development and if you're not doing
those things
then more often than not the gambit is
not going to work out in your favor
so e5 perhaps the first kind of mistake
by
white not advancing the lead in
development
not attacking the squares that have been
weakened by the opponent
instead just playing sort of a
reasonable looking move
okay so how should morphe respond chat
how should we respond
to e5 we are the side that has
captured the extra extra material we are
now honor bound
to defend it and uh try not to get
checkmated so we can win the game later
on
what should we do
how to continue with black hair
and yeah uh someone in the chat does
have the answer here
uh we should play the move d5 and
this might not be the most obvious to uh
to some of you i'm actually surprised
this is the first move
that got suggested suggested
tough to talk sometimes i would have
thought many many people were thinking
about the move knight g to e7 right this
seems like the most natural to me
and it's a fine move black is still
better because white has done a lot of
stuff wrong so far
namely playing the evans gambit but uh
it's not the best
that black can do and it's sort of
important to understand why
so what's black's biggest problem here
it's that this diagonal has been
weakened
by the move e7 e5 the light squares
have been weakened white is considering
threats like knight g5
considering threats like queen b3 and an
attack on the
f7 pawn so
with e5 thankfully white has given up
some control of these light squares the
really really important light squares
that white needs to control
has given up uh napoleon has actually
given up some of that control
by playing e5 no longer directly
defending the d5
square so what paul morphy's goal
should be is to sort of negate this
pressure
on this diagonal and find some way
to to finish development so knight ge7
is an efficient way of doing that but
perhaps d5 is a bit better
because it gets the critical light
squared bishop into the game
now what's different between this
position and
the last position where developing the
bishop was actually the mistake that
weakened the squares
well in this case our weakness is not
really on the queen side our weakness is
on the king side
thanks to our opening with e7 e5
and white's bishop now planted on c4
so we need this bishop out out on a
square like e6 out on a square like f5
where it can contribute to the game
maybe drop back to g6
and defend our light squared weaknesses
so that's why d5 is the best
move here it may not look like the most
natural move which might
be knight g to e7 but it is the best
move
because it helps to defend our weak
light squares
notably this is not a move that would
really be possible
if white had left this pawn on the uh
on the e4 square right it just defended
too many times here
so e5 allowing d5 allowing black to
enter the game with the light squared
bishop
and this is sort of the level of
understanding that paul morphy had
where his opponents did not this
thinking about chess
from the first move and understanding
what the actual point of the evan's
gambit is
and what the problems are for black to
solve so e takes d6
queen takes d6 played in the game now
white does go ahead and castle
but black is ready with knight ge7
blocking
the e file and ready to castle himself
white shows knight g5 and morphy just
castles
this pawn is defended twice and there's
no real major issues here
for uh for black black is is sort of
just winning
with the extra material it's sort of too
late now
for white to try the move queen to b3
it can simply be met with queen to g6
when again
morphy is ready to defend against this
onslaught
on the f7 pawn so white tried to switch
tactics here
and went after the h7 pawn on a
different diagonal
but once again thanks to morphe's strong
opening play
he was ready with bishop f5 and just
a winning position just an outright
winning position
now because morphy's morphe bishop f5
isn't as simple as it may seem because
white does actually have a bit of a
tactic here
to seemingly regain some material but
uh you know it's it's just going to be
winning for black in the end
but before we jump into that i want to
pause here because
this is the moment when you can really
truly say that black has won the opening
battle
and it's clear to understand why right
white didn't understand this concept of
attacking on the light squares
didn't really understand this concept of
taking over the center
and those are two really critical
concepts in the evidence gambit
so what's the point the point is you
have to understand
what the goal of your gambit is very
very few gambits the goal is to just
directly checkmate the opponent and so
if you're not
you know going for these goals if you're
just trying to make checkmating threats
like knight g5 like bishop d3
you're just not going to get a good
position it's just not how
chess works unfortunately
okay so questions here
hello yes hello everyone just joining
is this instinct instinctual so some of
it comes from prior knowledge
right some of it comes from
understanding you know uh the the goal
in the evans gambit and and that comes
from you know
looking at players better than myself
and sort of just analyzing the the
actual move so like what does b4 and the
evans gambit do well
it moves the bishop away from control of
the center so
the goal should be to control the center
right
uh what about queen h5 instead bishop d3
also bishop a3 has been mentioned
and yes so bishop a3 is why this is more
complicated than it may seem at first
and that's what happens in the game
but before we jump into that let's talk
about queen h5 instead
so queen h5 is a good idea trying to
attack all these squares
but again black is ready with with queen
g6 in this case
just defending uh just just defending
the light squares right
this was morphy's idea d5 activating
the bishop and also activating the queen
i guess i i didn't explicitly mention
that
but activating the queen to help defend
the light squares as well is
is also critical it's a good question
and then yeah
as someone in the chat has pointed out
uh white seemingly has a tactic here
with bishop a3
uh in the game white actually chose to
capture on f5 first which doesn't really
change anything
and then follows this up with bishop a3
when seemingly
black is losing the exchange and it's
true
black is losing the exchange but the
good news is
it doesn't really matter and the reason
for that
is black's opening problem of an attack
on the light squares
has completely disappeared there is no
more attack on the light squares
and by the way black is currently up two
pawns
so two pawns for the exchange is even
material and on top of that
it's actually now black who has the
better development in the more active
pieces so
black is still just winning we see queen
g6 in the game
bishop takes f8 capturing the rook
really what else can you do
and then morphy makes a very excellent
observation
and that observation is this knight is
defending the king
and this bishop has sort of nowhere to
go back on this diagonal
so we see morphy actually capture the
knight rather than the bishop here
now white has to spend a tempo to save
the bishop coming all the way back
to a3 and now after d takes c3
black just has three pawns for the
exchange the c3 pawn is very powerful
there's no way to develop this knight
and clearly black is is just winning
bishop c1 played in the game
coming back to the starting square uh
just queen back to g6
is great for morphe now bishop f4
developing out the other way this time
simply rook d8
bringing the final piece into the game
we see uh
queen c2 now knight to d4 now queen e4
and if you guys at home want to try to
find the
final tactic here go ahead and pause the
video
or let me know in the chat i'll open
this one up to the chat because it's
it's a fun end to a game
so block to move and win black to move
and win here
crypto has a couple good general
questions that i will get to
after we wrap up this game
knight f3 check doesn't quite work right
there's queen takes f3
okay rookie 8 doesn't quite work because
there's queen takes e8
c2 okay c2 is fine but it's not the
beautiful finish
c2 is fine yeah c2 is a fine move but
it's not the beautiful finish everybody
we're talking about morphe here
this game has lasted 170 years
you think it lasted 170 years because
murphy played c2
so some people in the chat do have it
now uh knight g3
is is the finish to this game uh taking
advantage of the fact that this queen
is attacked so there's no time to
capture the knight
and if queen takes g6 as played in the
game black's idea is of course
checkmates king has nowhere to go so
that's the beautiful finish to the game
and sort of
you know really shows how quickly things
can turn around if you're playing
you know seemingly fine moves right
seemingly you know attack attacking
moves like e5
but not understanding the point of the
opening in this case
the weak light squares
uh okay so we have some time left i want
to move on
to another game eventually oh but first
crypto had a couple questions so crypto
was asking
you know how many moves is the uh
how many moves is an opening so it's not
really number of moves it's more about
what position you're getting on the
board so
some people i mean there's no set
definition is the answer
as to what an opening is generally when
the main goals of the opening have been
achieved when both sides pieces
are fully developed when the kings are
castled or the kings are
reasonably safe and when there's sort of
some
situation in the center that you know
the situation becomes a bit clearer in
the center that's normally when you
say the the opening is finished but of
course there are games where
one side never gets fully developed and
they last like 40 moves so was that
whole game in opening
i don't know it's tough to classify
these things uh and lastly he asked
should you try to trade queens always as
black
and that is sort of the line of thinking
that they had in the 1850s
where every chess game was black takes
extra material
white plays for checkmate but not every
game goes like that
so the answer is as always it depends
some games if you're under attack really
good at trade queens other games
sometimes black's queen just turns out
to be the more valuable piece
and that's true general of a question
for me to to give you sort of more
guiding principles than that
okay now i wanted to turn back to one of
my own games this is a game
that i played against someone named
derek higgins
back in february of this year back when
chess tournaments were still a real
thing
and i wanted to show you sort of a
lesser example
of uh the wrong idea in a gambit once
again
so let's take a look uh i played d4 and
we're going to look for my perspective
we see knight f6 c4 e6
knight c3 bishop b4 and you guys know i
couldn't stay away
had to mention the f3 nimzo in a 10th
lecture in a row
and that's what we have that's what we
have here as well
derek continued with d5 i play a3 here
once again the point of my opening is to
control
the light squares this bishop is
interfering with my knights
controlling e4 so i want to kick it away
black chooses to capture instead but
seemingly
while this loosens my grip on the light
squares it actually advances my plan a
little bit
by helping to support my d4 pawn which
is going to need support
if i play e4 and black opens up the
center
so sort of a complicated way
to to play for the idea of the opening
but
it is sort of consistent regardless
now black continues with c5
i want to fix my double puns so i
capture on
d5 and now black plays a move which
is perfectly fine it's a good move butts
is sort of uh counter-intuitive
right so so far in this game what has
been going on i've played
f3 declaring my intention to play e4
fighting for the light squares so black
plays d5
not allowing me to gain control of these
light squares sort of fighting back
for those squares then we see a3 and
black again
removes the defender of the light square
seemingly black is fighting very hard
to keep me from playing e4 i take back
we get c5
takes so now you would expect black
to take back with the pawn right staying
consistent
still fighting for these light squares
instead black plays the move
knight takes d5 and this is one of those
moves that is sort of the exception
to the rule but it's also a move
you have to be very very careful with
and those things go hand in hand so if
you play an opening line
or if you find yourself in a position
where you're playing a move that
doesn't seem really to be that
consistent with your previous play
you have to be very very careful so
knight takes d5
if you know your stuff isn't even really
a risky line
but if you don't know your stuff black
could very easily
fall into a very worse position and
that's what actually happens
in this game so what's wrong with knight
takes d5 well
it allows white to play e4 sort of at
any moment
and in exchange for this black plays for
this very loose
concept of you know having an advantage
in development having an advantage in
activity and
immediately taking the fight to uh to
the player with the white pieces
by using this development to attack some
of these dark squares
like c3 so
the point i'm trying to make is that if
black
doesn't follow up with this attack on
the dark squares
and starts to sort of drift away and not
follow the point of the opening
that's when you're immediately going to
get into trouble
also that's a free pawn so i capture on
c5
and that's how i'm fitting this in to be
sort of a gambit
so let's take a look at how this one
goes wrong for black
first of all knight takes c3 is a legal
chess move so i guess i should talk
about it
it's just not a very good chess move
because
i'm able to take on d8 and play bishop
b2 and immediately win a pawn so that's
why
black isn't immediately capturing here
instead we see the move queen a5
which is the main move and a better move
then i follow up
with the move e4 which is again the
point of my opening trying to stay
consistent
and black does not actually continue
with knight take c3
so sort of a counter-intuitive opening
here black is a fighting for the dark
squares and then sort of giving up on
them
so why not knight takes c3 well the move
queen d2
is pretty good and again you're gonna
get something similar where after bishop
b2
knight a4 again i'm able to
win a pawn back on g7 so some tactical
ideas here to be aware of
black plays the move 97 and now white
plays bishop b3
to defend this pawn on c5
and for the third and final time again
black should not be capturing on c3
even though it looks tempting white will
play the move king f2
which is pretty much as good as castling
in this case uh
we get the king out of the center behind
sort of a pawn shield
and it's out of the way for rook to
invade in the game and this has actually
been done before
but white just gets a pretty comfortable
position after some pretty natural
development here
the queen has to go away and
you know white is able to develop out
quite naturally have some extra space
and gain some time on the queen okay but
all
none of that's really important what's
important is the move knight d7 here
so this is the beginning of the mistakes
by derek higgins so
let me get you in black's mindset here
here's what i think
black was thinking black was thinking i
sacrificed upon
i should take that back and that's just
the wrong way to approach this position
it's it's just
really the wrong way to to approach it
black didn't understand
the point of the opening and so the
second he wasn't sure
of what the theory was he ends up just
trying to regain the pawn
and when you don't follow the point of
your opening
that that's when things can get pretty
nasty pretty quickly here
so what should black have done instead
well black should have just castled just
castle the king
right black's idea is that there is a
lead in development and weaknesses
on white's queen side so what black
should expand this development
and continue out further and the theory
goes for quite a ways here
and is seemingly weird black actually
retreats with queen c7 because
queen b4 is often a good move for um
for white now bishop b5 is one of the
main ideas i think i recommended
a4 in my lecture series
and now black can play the move knight
d7
regaining this pawn and fighting for the
dark squares
on the queen side so what's different
about this
position than last position well really
the the only difference
is that black has gotten castled uh
so black's mistake was not understanding
that this opening
is about this lead in development and
using it
to get the king safe using it to
activate your pieces in the queen's site
and you can't really skip around and
skip steps like this
with knight to d7 again knight takes d5
is a risky move giving white control
over the e4 square
which white you know has already said
they wanted with the move f3
and if you deviate in a risky opening
like that
then you end up in trouble okay all of
that is to say
queen b3 now black should really castle
if black castle's here black is probably
still doing okay but instead
black continued out with knight c6 right
and at this point it's already uh a
little bit
too late for black to equalize in this
game
i continued out with a4 the point now
being
i want to go queen a3 and attack along
this weakened diagonal
once again black trades off the bishop
the dark squared bishop
weakening the dark squares and then we
see black nonchalantly not castling
and now the price will be paid for these
dark squared weaknesses
knight takes c5 is played in the game
but now queen a3
and these squares are already tough to
stop
black probably should have played b6 but
i think that
he may have been concerned about bishop
b5 when all of a sudden there's bishop
d2 ideas trapping the queen there's also
bishop takes c5 ideas
but this was probably black's best move
and best chance of staying in the game
uh black chose to play knight back to d7
which is of course just quite bad
so now black has given up the dark
squared bishop thereby
weakening the dark squares black then
spent a lot of time
before castling to capture the c5 pawn
opening up the dark square diagonal
and because of those reasons black is
now just just lost
out of the opening as we've seen before
so how to continue well you don't really
have to do anything crazy here with
white i just continue developing the
pieces with knight e2
black plays queen d8 sort of desperately
trying to block off this diagonal
i just continue now with knight d4
trading off
defenders of the dark squares and ready
to activate my bishop
we see now a6 which is trying to stop
knight b5 jumping in to d6 ideas
and now i simply just trade off this
defender as as i said
and plant the queen on d6 and yeah
this is just clearly now an opening
disaster
and black is quickly uh losing
in this game uh derek actually found
some pretty inventive moves to try to
get back into the game which i'll show
knight b8 was played which is rather
funny that the knight ends up back on b8
and black has officially undeveloped all
the pieces
sort of a similarity to the morphe game
there
but now queen g3 still is giving black
some trouble
kingside castles by black now i wanted
to play something involving bishop h6
but it doesn't quite work immediately
because queen f6
is there so i did a weird little stutter
step
we'll start first bishop c4 just
developing then after queen e7
now i want to play bishop h6 but queen
f6 works so
i do this weird little stutter step with
bishop to f4
threatening bishop d6 and bishop takes
b8 this induces my opponent to play
queen c5 and now that there's no queen
f6 bishop h6 is just winning material
then continued with g6 take on f8 take
on f8
and queen c7 not bothering to defend the
bishop just counter-attacking against
this undeveloped queen side
and we don't have to spend too much time
looking at the rest of the game
because it's pretty far from an opening
but at the end of the day
uh in a very tactical game
black does end up just sort of getting
checkmated here
here i think white's just up a full rook
and then
last move of the game uh well sorry yeah
i think this is the last move of the
game
wait to move and win everybody see if
you can find the finishing tactic
and then we'll we'll review this this
opening a little bit talk a little bit
more
about what happened here
and yeah chess king has the answer
always the tactician
rook takes h5 is the game ender
and here my opponent actually resigned
if you take this guy
then you get checked and checked
and checked this time with no escape
and i really wanted to show this game in
one of my lectures because
what's better than checkmating with the
boat
right we got the boat pawn structure and
we
we constructed a boat and delivered
checkmate on the same move
like what's what's not to love about
this checkmate i was very mad at my
opponent
for not allowing me to play it and
resigning uh i could have had the boat
immortal it would have been great
but wasn't meant to be black resigned
after rook h5
uh also very quickly just to mention if
pawn takes h5
then this check and again g3 is enough
in this case
all these moves are our checkmate
oh and sorry one more one more one more
king h4
then queen g3 or queen takes f6 but okay
so let's talk about this opening once
again what happened here what happened
here well
i took on d5 and black captures back
with the knight
not understanding that this opening
requires some urgency
by black and then by delaying castling
black ends up just in a much worse
position due to the weakness of the dark
squares
due to black not understanding the
danger of giving up this dark squared
bishop early on
and that is the story of the game
queen eth okay we're talking about some
checkmates now don't worry about it i'm
sure there's a thousand mates there you
guys might have a faster one
but you can't tell me that you have a
better mate than the boat
okay there's no better checkmates than
the boat
all right with this i want to move on to
i guess one more example we only have a
few minutes left
but i'm gonna pop over now to a game
between magnus carlsen and someone by
the name
of atlet groen
some norwegian name this was from a
norwegian championship
and it's way back in 2005 back when
magnus was not the world champion
although i i think he was a grand master
by by the time of this game and so i
showed you enough of gambits
going wrong first with napoleon just
completely misplaying
the evans gambit and then in that next
game which is kind of a sort of a gambit
you wouldn't call it a gambit directly
but black didn't understand the point
just played to regain the pawn instead
of castle the king and develop the
pieces
and that's why things went wrong so
let's take a look
at an example of a gambit going well
just wanted to show one fun game here
that i came across
so in this game magnus goes knight f3
and
we're gonna sort of blow past all this
stuff because
we are short on time and i want to get
to the full game here
so black has played queen b6
and now continues out with knight to e4
so what does this tell you well this
tells you that black is
very very interested in attacking the
dark squares
on the queen side right these are all
moves
bringing pieces to the queen side trying
to target these dark squares
and in this case it's just not the
greatest idea
for black because of the specifics of it
because white has the first move
you know things like this are a little
bit less likely to work from
the black side but at its core it makes
some sense right we see
white developing this bishop out black
attacking the bishop and
the bishop sort of becoming sort of
forlorn
over here on the h4 square sort of some
some hints of that first game i showed
against tim where the bishop was out of
play
so black is trying to attack on this
diagonal it makes some sense
magnus though just continues with e3
and we see bishop to b4 now bishop to d3
and now queen to a5 so
what's going on here black has launched
an attack on these
dark squares how should magnus
deal with this threat what do you guys
think what do you think in the chat room
what should white do here to deal with
this threat to the knight on c3
and yet thomas and jurgen and the
smasher all have
the right idea here so
at its core this looks rather similar
to those first couple games that we
looked at where one side's bishop gets
developed out a little early
blocked outside the pawn chain and as a
result these squares
on the queen side become weak the dark
squares in this case with this bishop
out on h4
now in the previous games we were
looking at it with colors reversed where
it was a bishop
stuck out on f5 or g4 but the same
principle
should sort of hold in theory here
but the key difference to understand is
that black has wasted
a lot of time in pursuit of this dark
squared attack
spending two moves getting this knight
into the game spending two moves
getting this queen into the game and
spending a couple moves
to defend the center first as well
whereas
magnus has been very very efficient
with uh with his moves right i didn't
say h6 was a waste of time by the way
because it
forced a wasted time by white as well so
that's why
i excluded those moves but aside from
those moves
let's look at what magnus played he has
played d4
and c4 and every move aside from that
has developed a piece every move every
move aside from this h6 bishop h4
where neither side really lost time
right black spent time on h6 white spent
time on bishop h4
so because of those reasons white is
perfectly justified in sacrificing
upon here because white has this lead in
development white is able and ready to
sacrifice the pawn on c3
without any real concerns so that's why
castles
is perfectly perfectly fine here no need
to
sweat this pawn on c3 no need to do
anything crazy like take on e4
giving up a great bishop just because
we're worried about the knight on c3
just castles is great black does go
ahead
and capture on c3 we see takes back
takes back the rook's attacked so now
rook a to b1
making use of the newly opened b file
right
black now continues by taking on c4 we
see it captures back
bishop back to b4 for outlet
and now i want to ask you guys we've
seen gambits
going wrong here we've seen them going
wrong
so let's see if you can identify where
white's strengths are and where black's
weaknesses are
in this opening and this is why i sort
of talked
from such a general perspective earlier
in the lecture
because sometimes your opponents just do
crazy stuff like outlet here like this
wasn't an opening magnus had prepped i
guarantee you
this is not something magnus had prepped
he just sort of finds himself in this
position where he sacrificed his
his b-pawn and he has this leading
development so it's
really useful to train this skill of
trying to identify
where the weaknesses are where your
advantages are where you can attack
so chat room in general you don't have
to give me a specific move
but what are the weaknesses for black
what are the strengths
for white in this position
such a waste of time to ask the audience
well if i don't ask you guys then you
might fall asleep and i would not like
that
so there are a lot of different
ideas going around so
the idea i'm seeing the most is talking
about this bishop on c8
and also talking about the queen's side
uh particularly
i imagine these two open files and that
is
the thing i would hope you guys would
notice i also hoped you would
potentially notice
the inclusion of h7 to h6
so this bishop combined with h7 to h6
combined with white's pressure on the
light squares
means that the light squares are what
white should be looking
to attack it's sort of the reverse of
what we saw in games one and two
in those games a bishop was trapped
outside the pawn chain
in this case the bishop is trapped
inside the pawn chain
unable to combat the threats on this
diagonal for one
and number two threats to squares like
f7
so magnus correctly identifies that the
light squares are where the attack
should be headed
and those other things mentioned in the
chat by the way are all great ideas the
king is stuck in the center
uh right we have good activity on the
queen side as well
but the key thing i wanted you guys to
notice was this weakness
on the light squares and that's where
magnus ends up winning this game
beginning with the move knight e5
attacking the weak into light squares
right h7 h6 by the way
i mentioned this because it weakens this
g6 square even further
black continues now with bishop to d6
trying perhaps
to you know just capture this knight and
gain back some of the light squares
and here magnus carlsen already i think
has the opportunity
to immediately win the game with some
stellar sacrifices
but first starts with f4 which is just
as good
black plays queen back to c7 desperately
trying to find some way to defend these
light squares on the
on the king side that this bishop cannot
access
magnus continued with queen e4 which is
sort of
not the best move in this case but black
doesn't find the way to punish
black tries to play b6 trying to develop
the bishop this way i guess or out to a6
but it's it's just too little too late
white to move with a winning advantage
here really there's numerous things you
can do but magnus finds the best
with knight takes f7 just ripping open
these light squares even further
understanding the point of the position
is that white black
lacks control of the light squares and
just breaking through
with that idea in mind queen takes f7
and now f5 just immediately ripping open
the light squares further
and bishop takes e6 after queen h5
knight d7 was
played and just f6 now opening up the
left file for the rooks and this game
does not last much longer
rook takes up 6 black sacrifices the
queen magnus doesn't even take it
and we see check check and mate
uh and magnus wins this game in glorious
fashion uh i don't actually know if he
won the norwegian championship in 2005
but i imagine with games like this he he
was probably probably up there with the
leaders
so that is going to conclude our lecture
here tonight
uh hopefully the main points you guys
got away from this
is that you can't just solely rely on
principles
in the opening it's really really
important to start thinking of it as a
chess game
from move one aside from that hopefully
you got a little bit better at
identifying these weak squares
and using them to guide your thinking
not as a replacement for thinking
but to guide your thinking
if you're watching live please head on
over to the twitch channel now we're
going to do a special segment of tactics
time
and if you've had enough chess for the
night or if you're watching the youtube
version i want to thank you very much
for watching
as always my name is caleb denby and i
will see you next time
you